We are asked what
number's represented
by the blocks shown.
So we could sit and
count all of these,
but let's think about this a
little bit more constructively.
So how many blocks do we have
in one of these squares here?
Well, let's see.
It's a 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10
by 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, so this is a 10
by 10 square.
It's going to have 100 blocks.
So this is 100.
This is another 100,
so we have two 100's.
So 200 blocks from these two.
And then let's count
these right over here.
We have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10 in each of these rows.
And we have four of these rows.
So 4 times 10, that's 40.
So we have 200 and
then 40-- 240 blocks.
Let's check our answer.
Now, you might be saying,
what's the whole point
of this exercise?
Isn't this just an exercise
in counting blocks?
But you might notice something
interesting happening here.
When I wrote this
2 here, it's making
you appreciate that that 2
doesn't just represent 2.
It's in the hundreds place,
so that 2 is actually
representing 200.
It's representing both of
these squares of blocks
right over here.
This 4 doesn't just represent 4.
It's in the tens place, so
it actually represents 40.
It's representing these
four groups of 10.
This is these two groups of 100.
This is these four groups of 10.
Let's do another one.
Oh, this is interesting.
So let's do the hundreds first.
So we have one group of
100 right over there,
so it's going to be 100.
And then let's see, we have
five groups of 10, so 150.
And then we just have 4 blocks,
so we just have that 4 there.
So let's check, make
sure we got it right.
And you see that this 4--
that's in the ones place.
So it literally
represents 4 blocks.
This 5, that's in
the tens place.
So it's literally representing
five groups of 10-- 1,
2, 3, 4, 5.
And this 1 is in
the hundreds place.
It literally
represents one group
of 100, this big
square right over here.